es scheint höchste Zeit Karl Lauterbach
eine gute Nachricht zukommen zu lassen
also eine arabische Weisheit will wissen
dass Fehler die Armen der Tugend sind
damit wäre dann klar die Geburt der
lauterbachschen Tugend dürfte
unmittelbar bevorstehen an politischen
Fehlern mangelt es ihm nicht lass
bodensack mit einer ersten Bilanz des
Bundesgesundheitsministers
die Woche war sowohl politisch wie auch
kommunikativ ein Debakel für Karl
Lauterbach am Donnerstag eine herbe
Niederlage bei der Impfpflicht im
Bundestag am Dienstag eine 180 Grad
Wende bei der corona-isolation verkündet
in einer Talkshow
ich glaube dass das zwar den
Gesundheitsämtern helfen würde dass der
symbolische schadenarbeit Corona ist
nicht mehr so gefährlich so verheerend
ist dass man diese isolationsordnung so
nicht machen kann Entsetzen beim
politischen Gegner wie beim politischen
Freund
das ist schon eine kommunikative
fehlerleistung es hat einfach schon eine
schräge Nummer ist
einfach so eine Verordnung in der
Talkshow zurückzuziehen und man kann den
Eindruck haben dass er für diese Aufgabe
überfordert ist Herr Minister ich hätte
gerne gewusst ob sie einen Rücktritt in
Erwägung gezogen haben danke nein habe
ich natürlich nicht
nach vier Monaten im Amt hat Lauterbach
Image ziemlich gelitten der Mann der
wöchentlich in Talkshow sitzt und
täglich twittert legt seit Wochen eine
umstrittene Performance hin die
Verwirrungen um den verkürzten genesenen
Status das hin und her um die vierte
Spritze das Gezerre um das Ende der
corona-beschränkungen das Gebirge
innerhalb der Koalition um die
Impfpflicht
Karl Lauterbach tut sich schwer das
merkt man von Anfang an eigentlich er
ist ein sehr wissenschaftlich denkender
Mensch er ist jemand der auch als
Abgeordneter sehr viel getan hat aber
das heißt eben nicht dass er automatisch
auch ein guter Minister ein guter
exekutiv-politiker ist damit fremdet er
bis heute und insofern ist es für ihn
glaube ich normal plötzlich so eine
Kehrtwende zu vollziehen wenn er neu
nachgedacht hat aber dass das
unglaubwürdig wirkt dass das
Rückkopplung auch auf öffentliche
Meinung und die Akzeptanz von Maßnahmen
hat das fällt ihm schwer mitzudenken
schon Lauterbachs Ernennung war für
viele Genossen eine Überraschung Olaf
Scholz wollte ihn eigentlich nicht im
Kabinett haben doch an dem Mediziner den
der corona-krise so oft richtig lag und
sich in der Bevölkerung wegen seines
Sachverstandes ein hohes Ansehen
erarbeitet hatte kam Scholz nicht vorbei
und deshalb haben sich anders kann man
das gar nicht sagen bestimmt die meisten
Bürgern und Bürger dieses Landes
gewünscht dass der nächste
Gesundheitsminister vom Fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er Karl
Lauterbach heißt er wird es neben seinem
kommunikativen Problem hat Lauterbach
noch eins in der eigenen Koalition die
FDP die möglichst alle
corona-schutzmaßnahmen loswerden will
doch auf Hilfe des Kanzlers kann
Lauterbach nicht bauen Scholz nimmt im
Sinne des macht der Hals vor allem
Rücksicht auf den Koalitionspartner
Lauterbach ist sicherlich ein Minister
der schon jetzt wackelt zumal man auch
weiß dass ein Verhältnis zum Kanzler
nicht besonders gut ist was man ja auch
immer daran sehen konnte das Scholz ihn
auch im Regen stehen lässt seine Politik
nicht unterstützt und das dann einfach
auch laufen lässt es waren vor allem
Wissenschaftler und Mediziner die seine
Ernennung begrüßt hatten endlich ein
Gesundheitsminister vom Fach auf
Augenhöhe der die manchmal komplizierte
Materie durchdringt von diesem
Vertrauensvorschuss ist nicht viel übrig
geblieben
das was wir ohne Frage kritisieren ist
die Tatsache dass sein
Kommunikationsverhalten eben häufig
unabgestimmt ist auch mit uns und auch
andere Beteiligten und ich glaube daran
muss sie dringend etwas ändern wenn er
mit seinem Ministeramt weiter Erfolg
haben möchte und wir erwarten dass wir
als Berufsstand in die Fragestellung die
wir uns relevant sind maßgeblich
eingebunden werden Karl Lauterbach muss
in diesen Tagen nicht nur bei Markus
Lanz feststellen dass die
regierungsrealität deutlich härter ist
als die des beliebten pandemieerklärers
der er einmal war